we're asked to solve for x let me just
rewrite this equation so that the
absolute values really pop out so this
is eight
times the absolute value
of x plus seven
plus four
in that same color plus 4 is equal to
negative 6 times the absolute value of x
plus 7
plus 6
plus 6.
now the key here at first it looks all
it looks kind of daunting it's this
complex equation you have these absolute
values in it but the way to think about
this is if you could solve for the
absolute value expression you could then
it then turns into a much simpler
problem then you can take it from there
so you can almost treat this expression
the absolute value of x plus seven you
can just really treat it as a variable
and then once you solve for that you it
becomes a simpler absolute value problem
so let's try to do that let's try to
solve for not x first we're gonna solve
for the absolute value of x plus 7
you'll see what i mean so i want to get
all of the absolute values of x plus 7
on the left hand side so i want to get
rid of this one on the right hand side
easiest way to get rid of it is to add
is to add
times the absolute value of x plus 7 to
the right-hand side we can't of course
only do that to the right-hand side if
these two things are equal and we're
being told that they are then if you add
something on this side the only way that
the quality will hold it if you still do
it on the left-hand side so let's do
that so plus
6 times the absolute value
of x plus 7
and i want to get all of these these
constant terms onto the right hand side
so i want to get rid of this positive 4
easiest way is to subtract 4 right over
there but if we do it on the left hand
side we have to do it on
the right hand side as well
and so what does this what does this get
us
what does this get us so our left hand
side if i have eight of something in
this case the something is absolute
values of x plus sevens but if i have
eight of something and i add six of that
same something i now have 14 of that
something
so that's going to be 14
absolute values of x plus seven
14 times the absolute value of x plus
seven
the four and the negative four cancel
out and that was intentional the
negative six and the six
x plus sevens cancel out or absolute
values of x plus 7's cancel out and that
was intentional and then we're left with
6 minus 4 which is just 2.
so that's going to be equal to equal to
2.
now just as promised we want to solve
for the absolute value of x plus 7. so
let's divide both sides by 14 to get rid
of that coefficient there
or that that factor or whatever you want
to call it the thing that's multiplying
the absolute value of x plus seven so
we'll just divide both sides by 14 and
we are left with the absolute value of x
plus 7
is equal to is equal to 2 over 14.
they're both divisible by 2. so this is
the same thing as 1 7. so just as
promised we've now solved for the
absolute value of x plus 7 but we really
need to solve for x so how can we reason
through this
so if i take the absolute value of
something and i got you 1 7 there's two
possible things that i took the absolute
value of i could have taken the absolute
value of positive 1 7 or i could have
taken the absolute value of negative 1
7. so this thing that we're taking the
absolute value of so x plus 7 could be
equal to positive 1 7
could be equal to positive 1 7 or
or
x plus 7 could be equal to negative 1 7
could be
equal to negative 1 7. and just think
about that for a second if this thing if
this thing right over here were equal to
1 7 you take its absolute value it'd be
1 7. if this thing it was negative 1 7
you take its absolute value it would be
positive 1 7. so that's how we got this
so now let's just solve for x
so if we subtract 7 from both sides
for this left-hand equation we get x is
equal to
minus and 7 we can rewrite as 49 over 7
which is equal to negative 48
over 7 so that's one possibility for x
and then the other possibility the other
possibility we would get x
is equal to so we have negative 1 7
negative 1 7 minus 49 over 7 we're just
subtracting 7 from both sides that's
what 49 over 7 is
and then this gets us to
negative 50
50 over 7. so the two solutions to this
this what we thought was a complicated
equation are negative 48 over 7 and
negative 50 over 7.